all right sue it's time for what women
really think I know we got a Carrie and
Kim standing by with guys ready to feel
some of these questions here
Kim ah who's got the first question back
in the day when I was in relationships
with a couple of girls not all at the
same time but it was more or less she
was so concerned about where I was so I
would get a phone call and she'd say hey
where are you and I'd be like I'm just
hanging out with my friends doing
whatever we're doing pretty much nothing
so her question to me is always oh well
would you mind maybe send me like a
snapchat or you know anything to let me
know exactly what you're doing cuz you
don't trust you bro
she's got baggage from other
relationship and she's bringing that on
that's why you do not ask the harder for
that [ __ ] if you if you don't didn't
figure it out you're bit stupid yourself
a good question asked Steve hard be like
hey Steve why are you so unfunny why are
you so popular what's up with that
mustache those are great questions my
question is why is it so damn important
for women to know exactly what we're
doing every second of the day I'm
guaranteed they're gonna ask the girls
those questions and the girls are gonna
say because men can't be trust our men
aren't responsible well this is what we
did fellas we surveyed this lovely group
of women behind me and we asked is it
because a women like details is how
we're built B we don't trust you or is
it C to make sure we approve of what
you're doing we do the answers B beep
all right I think the women are gonna
answer C C but I think the truth is B of
what you're doing
a whopping 71% of women say it see they
want to make sure that they approve of
what you're doing
[Applause]
all right so memory you ass it that way
why I did
I've had many long-term relationships
and let's just say many of my exes have
not made the right decisions while I
wasn't around I know and I'm not
surprised you've had many long-term
relationships
you seem unbearable to live with
long-term maybe it's one of those slow
poisons that you realize oh my god is
killing me over years and you're like I
think I'm done that Lauren Hill does
that Lauren killing me softly room and
wants have a pilot you want to treat me
like an independent woman but the moment
men want to get a little independence
you're like no you don't make good
enough judgments while I'm not around
you need to tell me what you're doing
Chris you're not gonna be a I and D epen
das you you don't know what I mean [ __ ]
you're not gonna be independent you
won't allow my ass when I was nervous I
didn't get all the letters right I and
II and II am so dumb you are really gone
for real one of my exes went out of town
without me knowing he couldn't get to
work on Monday he almost lost his job he
doesn't make sure your man makes it on
time to his job you got a bigger problem
do you choose baby on a man I've been
with ain't [ __ ] why are you choosing
[ __ ] people cuz you ain't [ __ ] either
[ __ ] another time he went and bought an
unauthorized toy attention what you can
authorize a Deez Nuts [ __ ] forgot my
face in thousand-dollar motorcycle so
needless to say I need to keep tabs on
him because he was bound to do something
ridiculous without my approval
[Applause]
look at this chorus of women clapping
yup listen this is so commerce and the
fact that you think you have to treat
your partner like a child imagine if I
got on live television
I looked off my girlfriend said my
girlfriend can't wipe her own ass she
needs a man to take care of her and make
sure she's doing the things you guys
would look at me like a sexist pig
but now we've gotten that a point
society where women are so elevated they
think it's perfectly acceptable to talk
type men like we're lapdogs like we're
not able to make decisions for ourselves
he wanted to buy a motorcycle okay you
guys got finances together maybe not the
most responsible thing but you want to
do something for himself and when you
try to time it out like this you're not
enforcing the fact that he has any sense
of manhood or independence in fact
you're working against that very notion
you know what theme RV is bad people
BuzzFeed Oh black people BuzzFeed are
you curious about the grumblings that
you're hearing from the 2,000 men yes
okay they think they don't need your
approval
what but listen to this though it's
really better than them saying they
don't trust you they don't trust you
they don't your judgement man you have a
question for us I do so this is based on
experience of my own as well
I was married a few years back and
everything's gonna click he's trouble
away he look like he's a mover he look
like he trying to apply for Survivor he
looks like he's gonna get cut from like
week two he's not gonna make it far in
the competition I end up losing my job
and decided to make a career change so
money wasn't coming in as steadily as
before I couldn't get her the things
that she wanted or take her out or as
much as we did before and eventually got
to a point where she was distancing
herself from me and kind of pushed away
from the relationship and ended up in a
divorce
she left I take I took it very seriously
as far as getting through the good times
and the bad and obviously she didn't why
do women basically give up or become
distant with it ya know that's your girl
that's your girl no it's not there's a
lot of why do women lose interest when a
man struggles financially is it a man is
supposed to provide is it B because you
start to lash out at us or is it seep
the man becomes a loser okay what do you
think the answers the real answer what
do you think they are answer be right
with this new perfectly set I think
they're gonna save you laugh out of us
but it's really see you become a looser
well more than half of the women saddest
be because you lash out at them so you
see how they trying to make themselves
be the victim of this this is what I
find the most interesting
so I've dated men who've made less than
me and one in particular decided to go
back to school shortly after we got into
a relationship so obviously he was
pressed financially at the time I didn't
mind but I think it did bother him
though for example on my birthday I
suggested a free concert for us to go to
he got so hung
over the cost of parking and when I said
I'll cover it his demeanor changed she
became annoyed and we ended up not going
at all and then another time on
Christmas we were living apart in
separate states so I got him a surprise
trip to come out and visit me he got
annoyed again and accused me of trying
to show him up because I knew that he
couldn't do a gift that was on that
level so that's funny because people
take like things that happened to them
in general relations like they
generalize so much this guy took what
happened to him and generalize and this
girl took what happened to her to answer
his generation so it's like two people
generalizing answering to each other
that don't work like that you ain't
gonna solve [ __ ] like that women tend to
not do that well when men make less than
men it was as the women don't do well
either yes that's true but they don't do
well they don't do well because they
don't feel desired as a man who are our
desires are very different so when women
say stuff like hey I don't want to die
who's you know makes less than me
because you know last shot that's not
the real reason what they want is
someone who's strong who's comfortable
himself who's assertive so when the man
makes less they feel like he's not gonna
have those traits and that's a big issue
where's men we don't mind if our partner
makes me less than us we don't even give
a [ __ ]
we less weigh less that's because of
gender roles we know that what a man
what a man who's gonna protect them now
our woman but a fair amount why do you
think they want someone taller why they
want someone who's bigger fair I mean
these are things that are already proven
in dating statistics I mean women date
men who were older than them or their
age movie make men who make as much as
them or more that's the way women tend
to date whereas men we date young
attractive whoo we don't care about the
financial credit status after it we
don't care this early Bob you know them
being close to our age it means why you
see older dudes with younger women all
the time
excuse me
my car tire
well done [ __ ] you don't even know what
tartar actually is like I don't make all
that money but I compensate yeah ain't
talked about my dick no no but you know
yeah sure anyways uh yeah other
qualities hold on leave it stare all you
want lookit no not there yeah you
staring I'm not staring Stephanie I'll
be home in 30 minutes that's gonna be
the longest running joke that we have so
yeah all is to say listen what I hate
about dating shows like these if you ask
women direct questions they're always
gonna find a way to not seem like the
bad guy that's not just a woman people
people in general general so that's
pretty much it for today's video tell us
what you guys think were we accurate in
our assessments do you guys agree with
us you guys agree disagree with some of
our statements let us know what you
think
all right so that's it for today's video
if you guys liked that be sure to LIKE
subscribe Facebook YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main bits follow
us on Instagram all that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you want it
don't need a little bit money you know
give us a little thumbs up then we do a
little I definitely went the wrong
direction job but that's it so you know
thanks holler a dollar makes me holler